you're looking at mac qataro he will be
the manager in the absence of kevin cash
the uh
bench coaches for both clubs will be the
acting managers
well taking the mound tonight for the
new york yankees is going to be
left-hander jordan
montgomery making his sixth start of the
season
very big game for the yanks this is a
two-game game
at the end of it the yankees will be one
behind in the lost side or
three and well go hitting 284 to start
play tonight
and he lines it into left back toward
the corner
fair ball into the corner after at
gardner extra bases for margaux
and at second with his seventh double of
the year
to start this game and by the way if
they
have not turned up the volume on the
mics around
the dugouts then this is going to be a
very
loud and chirpy affair double down into
the corner and you can hear that raised
dugout erupt
like it was a little again you know the
question the obvious question i think
everybody has
in mind is are we going to see fireworks
tonight couple of teams
fired up i think they'll try to put last
night behind him for the time being
and there's a lead off double for
margaux rose arenda hitting
second he shoots one deep into left
field
gardner will go back and that one is
gone
off the bound of a rosarina his first as
a ray
and it puts the rays out in front two to
nothing
tonight just listen to that dugout now
with the two-run lead nobody out here's
austin meadows
and there's a shot into right field
that's going to one hop that ball out
there
cochman with the rebound and the throw
comes into second out of base hit but
three straight hits have opened this
game for the rays
but the the the dugout chatter i
i mean you haven't heard it like this i
mean you've been able to hear things
that you've never heard before
but you haven't heard it quite like this
mike browsos
thrown out in his head yesterday at a
101 mile an hour fastball by erolus
chapman
and now digs in against george
montgomery takes he comes home swinging
another fly ball deep in the air to left
field gardner
turns and looks and that's how you
answer it a two-run homer
for mike brusso four-nothing raise in
the first
oh boy that has got to feel really
really good
[Applause]
i'm not sure dwayne that these were the
fireworks that we were looking for
race are given fireworks the veteran
charlie morton now staked
to a comfortable four to nothing lead
before he even throws a pitch this will
be his fifth start
he had to come out against the yankees
with some right shoulder inflammation
this will be his first start back off
with the il
line the third caught by wendell to
retire the side
two men left no runs and at the end of
an inning 4-0
tampa bay here's morton ready and now
pitching
curve struck him out swinging went down
and in and smith tags him out just to
make sure
morton records his second strikeout and
pull and he comes fastball
up and in and gets it by sanchez strikes
him out
number three for morgan now morton from
his wine he pitches
curve he struck him out swinging and
charlie morton strikes out the side
here in the second inning and boy if the
rays ever needed a boost after that full
run first
bring it to the count to le mayhew
runner goes the pitch is lined into the
left
gonna be caught out there and a throw
headed back to first they're gonna
get the double play so lamarhu
lines to left and rozarena
making that catch doubling up wade who
was breaking you love that double play
and right there
tied away by the time he reads it it's
too late
again had to feel that he got a little
bit of revenge when he hit the two-run
home run to make it a four-nothing game
there's a swing and a fly ball
to right center field and fairly deep
back out of this hicks to the wall
it's a two-homer game mike rosso goes
oppo
his second home run tonight his fifth
home run of the season
and the rays get on the other side of
the slam five
nothing say what 24 hours ago i wonder
how many yankee fans have
really heard about mike brasso he may
never let them
forget about him now what an answer in
the fourth that's where he stands at
five nothing
and renfro gets plunked by heller
now the umpires are going to convene on
that one and that is the danger you have
when warnings are issued before a game
where if a ball gets slightly away from
a pitcher
there's a possibility he could get
thrown out well here's a young kid that
just lost a pitch there's no intention
whatsoever here and that's where it
becomes a fine line you talked about it
michael
and i mean this is ridiculous every once
in a while you're going to lose pitches
and you have to be smart enough as a
pitcher
i believe this wow and carlos mendoza is
going to say i mean really
and the yankees are in a bind trying to
get all these outside of the bullpen now
you just threw out one of their players
it's over overly cautious by the umpires
obviously and with the history and
what's happened
and caught by lemayo for the second half
boy went a long way and caught that on
the backhand for the second out
yeah a little looper right there great
play by le mayhew this ball gets down it
gets through and it's probably another
run
so one down and here's uh clint frazier
high fly ball down the left field line
will it stay fair
yes it hits the foul pole and the
yankees are on the board
a home run for frasier it's 5-1
i'll tell you if you're a hitter and you
see that go off the foul ball what a
relief
to not watch it hook foul and the 1-1
there's a line drive base hit the left
field the
yankee catcher
margot gets it in up the middle and the
yankees are still alive a base hit for
lemayo
here comes gardner he'll score and that
will bring up luke boyd as a tying run
as the rays lead five to two in the
pitch
ground ball that should do it brasso off
the slider
and it's over the rays win this one five
to two
crosso takes care of voight and the rays
go to 26 and 12 and win this series
over the new york yankees